que les gens se posent aujourd'hui on
n'est pas chez ubisoft
à côté d'un sponsor mais en fait ce
qu'on va faire c'est convaincre le maire
d'auby avant de rejoindre
alors on se retrouve tout de suite avec
le masque et zombies et ça va être
rigolo c'est parti
après c'est juste pourquoi je pourrais
de zombies parce qu'aujourd'hui je viens
d'acheter son billet où il est ici on va
mettre tout de suite des taux la poste
était formel mais gaffe à l'aide de la
mort vient de s'excuser aujourd'hui on
se retrouve chez ubisoft est en train de
jouer à soumillon
j'ai donc le gamepad dans les bras il ya
deux caméras actuellement une demande on
va les deux faces coûts et une derrière
qui sud-rail gemba beaucoup aussi
est ce qu'on va faire passer je vous
regarde en haut à droite comme le voir
ma tête tout comme la députée action je
vous tiens au regard desquels pad et ça
sera un week-end alors j'espère quelques
tuniques rouges s'est pas trop mal c'est
pas il faut de luxe cas première trop
génial mais de quoi se gaver alors c'est
parti
quand balle juste à côté d'une minute
avait trop peur et je joue sur une télé
mais immense seul cochon la vidéo juste
d'après tuyaux pour la chaîne secondaire
que pour aller voir à quelqu'un dans la
structure un petit peu commencé ici chez
ubisoft
et sur quoi je joue la dgi l'ambiance et
que c'était en juillet
celle ci sera de voir un fléau
un brouillard de mort courir à lagardère
et les hommes version secours sous
citrix int
car john agnello casimir ceux qui
n'entendent pas ces menaces oui comme
pendant les soins tawera vient et le
monde indique la c ie session sera
purifié par des anges noirs joie pur et
parfait qu'il renaisse
mais le bas
en tout cas
alors
c'est l'intro du jeu je fais tout à
l'heure une minute tester les colorants
parce que tu étais mon pote que l'on
pensait qu'il y avait un blocage à
l'outil del cacho quoi bref là ça a
l'air de tout bien marché ceux-ci cohade
et j'espère que le jeu est cool c'est
parti peut-être ludivine à l'esprit
alors et bien bouché
j'aimerais sa place ils savent pas c'est
quoi ton
une tendance
j'attends reste sur deux victoires toi
j'te dis pas je suis maman
dans le métro dans métro
les skis
c'est pas le destin vont commencer
quelques conflits dans le thème la cia
de soul dont toi l'heure tranquille
c'est martin au niveau des looks 14 mai
par les skis les corps comme ça les
fatigue est reproché à ces super en
présence et c'est le truc je sens qu'il
ya des gens de bref je suis ému et de
venir parce que j'étais trop aux caisses
et participons ce coup là joli bourg
joly les faits pour moi c'est la france
à ouvrir
comme si on gagne pas d'allant donc
chatel a joué plus que jamais joué à la
lumière
je te rappelle
3 ok donc c'est jusque là que je les
fais la dernière fois maintenant je ne
sais plus du tout alors c'est parti là
pour le coup je sais pas du tout ce qui
m'attend j'ai jamais joué
l appareil plus que c'était une démo du
jeu ne s'est pas d'histoire en quoi sert
à rien à voir mais la voilà maintenant
ce que ça vaut
la valeur d'achat sa vie sans sa mission
heureusement il ya mieux avec les
animaux
je sais pourquoi ok mais bon on peut
voir sur le gabon
moi moi
or
voilà
ok j'ai eu la tablette survivants il dit
ok mais en attendant les chiottes
il faut john o'shea lot alors je vois
j'ai galéré un petit peu à faire à cinq
trous entre ce qui se passe à l'écran ce
qui se passe on n'aime pas donc les
indices qui font moins la fatigue badge
d'accès à baigts d'accès à internet
c'est mon club c'est énorme
où est il alors est ce que ne peut pas
chez québec fait l'objet ici
ok bouche d'égout alors je regarde vite
fait moi je suis où je suis là non moi
je suis un petit karaoké ça c'est quoi
ça c'est pareil pour activer le
générateur auquel vous pouvez aller vous
verrez c'est ouais ça sur auzon be moi
je vous dis c'est sage l'art
ok pourquoi classement spalletti
commentaire ok donc avec la beauté même
si wes et lahore a bien déjà pas mal an
c'est super cool on peut voir sur sur la
mi-match du gamepad l'objectif du ces ça
calme
et surtout parce que c'est par ici je
vais d'ailleurs très bien cela n'empêche
pas j'allais il faut toujours à bagdad
des baltes ex
c'est moi ou il et je me le demande pas
pourquoi j'ai pas être bloqués comme ça
je me sens super combiné de la capacité
d'accès et pas d'abc bordel que je parte
journée c'est maintenant à peser face à
ce qu'on peut faire
je martèle très touchant balade en
baisse le royal ça où elle se trouvait
le laisse cas du président m'oblige à
une formation basque garder direct je
vais recevoir des compensations meurt on
est chaud lapin bélier
jaurès et romantique la bascule à trois
par équipe et toutes ses primes à oui je
crois que sa charge un mondial trait sur
sa version sans utiliser mon nom
[ __ ] mais où est le patch d'accès ok
d'accord je suis à peine qu'on bon c'est
parti il ya dans cette nuit dans cette
zone se trouve un rescapé
quoi tu sais mon radar
qu'est ce que tu me parles de radars des
proviseurs démunis à attendre tapez 1 ok
ok mais quand on tape sur le cas pas de
se voir la droite
sam est une espèce d'onde ok donc ça je
pensais pour vous et écoutez gilles
muller très bien maintenant on va
chercher jusqu'où est le suivant parce
qu'à la base c'est comme ça qu'on veut
pour trouver rescapés précédent à tous
les coups dans la pièce où il ya le à
dardilly
donc je crois qu'il dans cette pièce ok
c'est cool il est ainsi pièce
aux fins
ça veut dire
alors hop regardant à droite donc le
pistolet d'accord dont ils nous
appellent commencé à remettre en eau
ok d'accord auquel seulement choquée
c'est ok on va fermer alors la
particularité tous les toits les yeux
avec un si j'appuie lâche que safran ok
ça prend quelqu'un sait ce qu'il aura
que des munitions devrait éviter de
faire ça a très bien préparés nous
ok pour penser à d'autres alors je pose
toi te rendormir
alors on l'a fait juste avant parce que
j'avais peur de mourir comme une grosse
merde donc c'est parti maya les eaux
dans la gauche taxes je commence à me
faire un petit peu là
c'est pas de refus c'est pas de refus
c'est pas que j'aimerais vivre
ok on acquiesce [ __ ] franchement c'est
beau il ya un chacun pourra alors le
chargement déchargement dzeko pourrait
se dire que tu es mort
à
alors ça c'est génial alors sachez chers
ok ouah ça marche bien plus ok donc en
fait l'homme en train de caler la pièce
les gens savoir si à ce qu'on trouve
recherche par mon genre et tous ces
envois 360° tout là haut la warwick
ardiden c'est génial
y'a quoi à gauche
d'accord ok ok alors après nous met donc
une croix donc je suppose qu'on peut le
fruit voilà benoît fouillet il ya des
munitions fermer les prendre tu sais mon
nom merde on peut les mettre dans un sac
choix donc pas de mettre dans le sac
dans le sac
ok on peut pas bon tant pis karine et on
va fouiller le suivant est ici fouillez
vide évoquée ne te tais toi qui es tu
meurs en plus tu ne sers à rien aux
survivants anvers beaucoup ramasser
journée pour attaquer ça n'empêche que
le truc utile sera sûrement dans ses
valises
voilà donc c'est parce que je pensais on
peut vraiment les mettre dans mon sac
voilà ici il y six voix l'amicale ok
parfait
ok il y avait quelque chose je tiens
j'aime pas ce n'est pas des zombies au
[ __ ] [ __ ] c'était un rat or foie
gras j'ai toujours j'ai toujours détesté
les rats sains
j'étais sur ok on ouvre c'est un
survivant
c'est un survivant ça dégage dégage
dégage ce niveau je obligé d'y aller il
va se lever d'un coup oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] faudrait tuer lui l'a foutu et
lui c'est bon we want you down shut
ok faut aller maintenant ok tout cas
bien son boulot mais au québec
lt jédir scanner jeune homme j'ai déjà
scanné sincères plus à rien bon si tu
veux ok y'a rien voilà ok super à la
nôtre côté hockey et là ok donc il ya
quelque chose d'autre que
d'effectivement voir y aller quand faut
y aller faut y allait encore vous dire
que la porte soit ouverte à peut-être si
lucas la clé non ok bon bon bon bon on
va devoir passer par la radio
tu connais ces bons est mort vive dans
le sac sera fini ok ultra stressant
c'est qu'on accepte dans le sac et kung
fu les gens le jeu continue c'est à dire
vous pouvez quand même faire des
manières par le rugby et ça je peux vous
dire que ça fait vraiment pas plaisir ya
un an tiroirs alors je suppose que c'est
ici qu'il va falloir qu'on se calme
parce que la pièce de la clé de l'autre
truc doit doit se trouver ici sur moi
dans ce cas car la raconte
si vous avez un mal de dos ne jouait pas
au bio il faut faire des 180 degrés ça
serait plutôt que de me faire du mal au
dos déjà qu'ils étaient surveillés dans
un monde de brutes
alors qui sait que ça ok ouvrir
regardez votre wii ou placards il n'est
rien génial j'ai le dos à mes placards
bon bah tu en as journal la gruyère
je me fais chier bordel go cette fois on
a deux badges ou on a le badge au pardon
la vidéo a été arrêté à droite je vais
juste la roue mais je reviens religion
excusez moi donc la vidéo et l année
vous voyez que tout le monde alors c'est
parti on est ok pour tourner en arrière
on a eu le beh donc je poserai pas rater
d'autres trucs donc je cherche [ __ ] ou
pas je prends trois mille ans
et là j'avais beau jeu pour ce qu'elle
est une vitre en toute sincérité je
pensais que le barca c'est une vie faire
du bruit se taper une invasion de remise
sur la gueule c'est parti
méchant rigidité à peine parle t shirt
et en fait je vous incite à bah en fait
à devenir parano avant sur des abris
anti zombies pour commencer à les voir
au bout d'un an toutes avec les bruits
les produits mais bon dieu oui il a un
truc j'ai trop bien vu sur abollivier
est un gros voilà il y avait peut-être
la somme les bons alors attendez on va
aller or je n'aime pas ce à quoi il est
la famille jack
j'ai perdu la vie en tombant au cutter
un copain savage et de la jeune à la vie
ça va sortir c'est bon ou on la pas et
toi avez très alors écouter ce qu'ils
disent peut-être que cela soit utile
london bridge donc c'est un landreau
fait donc en fait l'histoire en gros
c'est l'histoire d'une infection une
base c est une grosse infection à
londres et que bas ont incarné
survivants au niveau de jeu touché c'est
comme iliad indisponible pendant une
mission beaucoup jusqu'ici
k
oui donc je disais à un désir légitime
l'emprunt grec je disais au niveau du
hockey jusqu'à tuer la demande de
calibre de survivants ou en fait c'est
un très bon alors vous devez commencer à
partir que vous soyez à saint plancard
en terme de jeu il ya le mode où vous
pouvez donc il faut se garder est allé
moi donc on vous revivez vous incarnez
un ou deux survivants à chaque fois
merde merde vous accabler un nouveau
survivant des coûts mouret et avec
lequel vous allez chercher les affaires
du monde avant bref la jam je suis dans
la merde je n'aime pas ça vraiment ok
donc je vais sortir dehors et va j'ai
peur
j'ai peur j'ai peur je le souhaitais et
quand je fais je t'en parle de gens en
mangent à faire le tour
ok faut juste que je passe là ok même
c'est très très très très très rassurant
à ce que je pouvais voir à quelle est la
vertu à son côté en fait